A man walks into the main branch of the San Francisco Public Library one Monday earlier this month. He's a balding gentleman named John Peters, and he's looking for books by the Marxist political theorist, Antonio Gramsci.
本月早些时候的一个周一，一名男子走进旧金山公共图书馆总馆。他是一位名叫约翰·彼得斯的秃顶绅士，正在寻找马克思主义政治理论家安东尼奥·葛兰西的著作。
He's an Italian radical. And what I'm seeing is everything has been taken out several years ago. I'm wondering, are these stolen? Or has somebody-- and I know of one case of this-- deliberately not wanted people to see these books?
他是一位意大利激进分子。我看到几年前所有的书都被借走了。我很好奇，这些书是被偷了吗？还是有人——我知道有一个这样的案例——故意不让人看到这些书？
If this is a conspiracy to suppress the 20th century's greatest theorist of cultural hegemony, it is not a very effective conspiracy. It takes the helpful librarian less than two minutes to find, on the shelves of the fourth floor, a book of Gramsci's selected political writings.
如果这是一个压制20世纪最伟大的文化霸权理论家的阴谋，那这个阴谋并不怎么高明。负责的图书管理员不到两分钟就在四楼的书架上找到了葛兰西的政治著作选集。
So here's the call number. So that's how you find it on the shelf, OK?
这是索书号。你就是这样在书架上找到它的，明白吗？
OK.
明白。
Five of us went to libraries around the country that day, according to the reference desk. And one of the things that we found everywhere were even-tempered, unflappable librarians. Like at the Palo Verde Public Library in Phoenix, a library user named Cindy, in a maroon sweatshirt and fanny pack, broke into song to get the librarian to understand exactly which Amy Grant Christmas album she wanted.
据咨询台说，那天我们有五个人去了全国各地的图书馆。我们到处都发现了一些脾气温和、沉着冷静的图书管理员。比如在菲尼克斯的帕洛佛得角公共图书馆，一位名叫辛迪的图书馆用户穿着栗色运动衫，背着腰包，突然唱起歌来，好让图书管理员明白她究竟想要哪一张艾米·格兰特的圣诞专辑。
No.
不。
(SINGING) Mary, did you know that your baby boy--
（唱歌）玛丽，你知道你的男婴吗——
Oh, I've heard the song.
哦，我听过这首歌。
That same day on the Blackfeet Indian Reservation in Montana, at the Medicine Spring Library, a woman asked the librarian, Aaron Lafromboise, if they have anything on the Motokiks, the traditional women's society in the tribe.
同一天在蒙大拿州的黑脚印第安保留地，在医药泉图书馆，一位女士问图书管理员亚伦·拉弗隆博伊斯，他们是否有关于莫托基克斯（Motokiks）——部落里传统的妇女协会——的资料。
You know, I don't know if there's anything actually written about Motokik.
你知道，我不知道是否真的有关于莫托基克斯的书面资料。
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah, one of my aunties is in there. And so when I got my Indian name, she sang me an honor song from the Motokiks. So it was really amazing.
是啊，我的一位阿姨就在里面。所以当我得到印第安名字时，她为我唱了一首莫托基克斯的荣誉之歌。那真的很神奇。
Really?
真的吗？
So I'm thinking you might have to search a little more.
所以我认为你可能得再多查查。
They look for books together and don't find much. The books are written mostly by non-natives and men, which can I say? Good example of cultural hegemony.
他们一起找书，但没找到多少。这些书大多是由非原住民和男性写的，我能说什么呢？这真是文化霸权的绝佳例子。
Same afternoon, on the other side of the country in the Jackson Heights branch of the Queens Public Library in New York City, upstairs in the children's section, high school kids hide out on the floors of the stacks. A teenager by the computers downloads an immigration form, I suppose, for her parents. This is, everybody says, the most ethnically-mixed neighborhood in Queens, with books in English, Spanish, Chinese, Korean Urdu, Hindi, and more. Two happily confident third graders, named Katherine and Adam, friends from the libraries after school program, Stacks, walk up to the librarian with a request.
同一天下午，在纽约市皇后区公共图书馆杰克逊高地分馆的另一端，在楼上的儿童区，高中生躲在书架区的地板上。我猜，一位正在电脑旁下载移民表格的少女是为她的父母准备的。大家都说，这是皇后区民族融合程度最高的社区，这里有英语、西班牙语、中文、韩语、乌尔都语、印地语等多种语言的书籍。两个快乐自信的三年级学生，名叫凯瑟琳和亚当，是图书馆课后项目“书架”的朋友，走上前向图书管理员提出了一个请求。
I want to know that any books have words but no pictures.
我想知道有没有只有文字没有图片的书。
Yes. Words but no pictures?
是的。只有文字没有图片？
Yeah.
嗯。
Most of our books have at least a little picture.
我们大多数书至少有一点图片。
Even the chapter books have drawings at the start of each chapter, the librarian explains. The kids let her know that this is acceptable. Not ideal, but acceptable.
图书管理员解释说，即使是章节书在每一章的开头也有图画。孩子们告诉她这可以接受。虽然不是最理想，但可以接受。
I want to have a book with a challenge reading because-- do you know I'm almost fifth grade?
我想读一本有挑战性的书，因为——你知道我快五年级了吗？
No, you're third grade. How can you be almost fifth grade?
不，你才三年级。你怎么可能快五年级了？
OK, here, this book might be--
好了，给你，这本书可能——
But I want a really challenge. I want a challenging one. And I think I know there's a one here. Can you go to the front over there?
但我想要一个真正的挑战。我想要一本有挑战性的书。我想我知道这儿有一本。你能去那边前面看看吗？
He marches the librarian towards the books for older kids. Best as I can figure out, Adam somehow got it into his head that day that he had just had it with picture books. And as soon as he said this, Katherine was like, oh, me too. Though once Adam walked away, she told me it was her own independent decision.
他领着图书管理员走向大孩子的书架。据我所知，亚当那天不知怎么钻进了牛角尖，受够了图画书。他刚说完，凯瑟琳就说，哦，我也是。虽然亚当走开后，她告诉我那是她自己的独立决定。
It's that now that I'm bigger, I don't want to really have more pictures. I want to mostly just use my imaginations for reading.
就是因为我长大了，我真的不想再看太多图片了。我大多只想在阅读时运用我的想象力。
People use the library for so much more than books, though. In just that one Monday, the five of us who went out to record, we witnessed a woman printing out fliers to find her lost dog. We witnessed old people getting help with their email. One librarian told me that in her job, you really get in touch with just how many people really do not know how to use computers at all.
不过，人们使用图书馆不仅仅是为了看书。就在那个周一，我们五个出去录音的人，亲眼目睹了一位女士打印寻找丢失狗的传单。我们目睹了老人在寻求电子邮件方面的帮助。一位图书管理员告诉我，在她的工作中，你真的会接触到很多人根本不知道如何使用电脑。
We saw a homeless guy research apartments he might be able to afford. We heard about power tools you could check out to do your home improvements when you have a place and lights for seasonal affective disorder you can check out. A library got on the phone and then arranged for a patron to get a new walker and get it delivered to him.
我们看到一个无家可归的人在搜索他可能负担得起的公寓。我们听说可以借到电动工具来做家居装修，如果你有房子的话，还能借到用于治疗季节性情绪失调的灯具。一位图书管理员打了个电话，安排一位读者得到了一台新的助行器，并送到他手中。
Will you be there between 5:00 and 7:00 tonight?
你今晚5点到7点之间会在那里吗？
Yes.
是的。
Yes. 5:00 and 7:00 tonight works.
好的。今晚5点到7点可以。
The librarian from suburban Detroit that I spoke with, Annie Spence, described libraries the best, I thought.
我采访的底特律郊区的图书管理员安妮·斯宾塞对图书馆的描述最好，我认为。
I always say that it's the only place-- well, it's one of the last places you can go that you don't have to buy or believe in anything to come in. You can just come, and we'll help you, no matter what your question is. We'll try to figure it out with you.
我总是说它是唯一的地方——嗯，它是你最后能去的地方之一，进去时你不需要买任何东西，也不需要相信任何东西。你尽管来，我们会帮助你，无论你有什么问题。我们会试着和你一起弄清楚。
In the Harry Potter books, there's this place called the Room of Requirement. The way it works is you walk three times in front of this certain patch of wall at Hogwarts, thinking, like, I really need a coffee. And then suddenly in that room a coffee shop will appear. Or, I need a place to make my magic potion in secret, and then a room with all the ingredients for your magic potion will appear.
在哈利·波特系列书中，有一个地方叫“有求必应屋”。它是这样工作的：你在这段特定的墙前走三次，想着，比如，我真的需要一杯咖啡。然后突然间，那个房间里就会出现一家咖啡店。或者，我需要一个地方秘密地制作我的魔法药水，然后一个装满魔法药水原料的房间就会出现。
Libraries are like that. But in real life. That's what they do. And today on our program, we have stories of very unlikely uses for these Rooms of Requirement, all driven by people who want something very, very specialized. Something which, in every single story in today's show, the library is able to deliver. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
图书馆就是那样。但在现实生活中。这就是它们所做的。今天在我们的节目中，我们有关于这些“有求必应屋”非常不可能的用途的故事，所有这些都是由想要非常非常专门的东西的人驱动的。在今天节目中的每一个故事里，图书馆都能提供。这里是来自WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, In Praise of Limbo. So we start our show today with a library in a very unusual place, and with people who want something very unusual from that library. Zoe Chace explains.
第一幕，赞美边缘。今天节目开头，我们先从一个非常不寻常的地方的图书馆讲起，还有那些从那个图书馆里想要一些非常不寻常的东西的人。佐伊·蔡斯来解释。
The library sits on the border between Canada and the US. I mean, literally on the border. Like there's a faded black line running along the floor to show you which country you're in. The books are mostly in Canada. The front door is in America. So entering from the US is easy.
这个图书馆坐落在加拿大和美国的边界上。我的意思是，就在边界上。就像地板上有一条褪色的黑线，告诉你你在哪个国家。书大多在加拿大。前门在美国。所以从美国进入很容易。
But if you're coming from the Canadian side, to get to the door, you have to venture for about 20 yards into American territory on an American sidewalk. How can you tell you've crossed over? Flower pots. A row of flower pots. Yeganeh Torbati is a Reuters reporter who was there recently.
但如果你从加拿大一侧来，要到达门口，你必须在美国人行道上的美国领土内冒险走大约20码。你怎么知道你已经越界了？花盆。一排花盆。耶加内·托尔巴蒂是路透社的一名记者，最近在那里。
So the flower pots are there to demarcate the border between the United States and Canada.
所以花盆在那里是为了划定美国和加拿大之间的边界。
It's just-- it's like, sorry, we just have to show you that this little line exists, but we're trying to make it as sweet as possible.
这只是——就像，抱歉，我们不得不向你展示这条小线确实存在，但我们正试图让它尽可能地可爱。
And in the spring, those flower pots are blooming, and it's quite beautiful. Of course, when I was there, it was quite dead. So it's really just a line of flower pots with dirt in them.
春天的时候，那些花盆开花了，非常漂亮。当然，我去的时候，它们已经枯死了。所以它真的只是一排装着土的花盆。
The place is kind of famous, gets tourists. When Barack Obama was speaking during a state visit from the Canadian Prime Minister, he mentioned the library as this harmonious symbol of Canadian-US ties. A library is an inherently welcoming place. Its whole ethos is this is for everybody. That's the spirit of this library in two countries at once.
这个地方很有名，吸引了游客。巴拉克·奥巴马在加拿大总理进行国事访问时发表演讲，他提到图书馆是美加关系和谐的象征。图书馆是一个天生受欢迎的地方。它的精神就是，这是为了每一个人。这就是这个同时位于两个国家的图书馆的精神。
That's not why we're talking about it, though. We're talking about something happening inside the library that's making things kind of tense. That's why Yeganeh was there. She covers immigration. She's been writing about the travel ban since January 2017. And the list of countries has changed as the ban has changed. But Iran? Iran has always been on the list of banned countries.
但这并不是我们讨论它的原因。我们谈论的是图书馆内部发生的一些让情况变得有点紧张的事情。这就是耶加内在那里的原因。她负责移民报道。自2017年1月以来，她一直在撰写关于旅行禁令的文章。国家的名单随着禁令的变化而变化。但是伊朗？伊朗一直都在被禁国家名单上。
There are a lot of Iranian students in the US here on single-entry visas. Single-entry means if they leave, they can't just turn around and re-enter. They can't go home to see their families. And because of the travel ban, their families can't visit them here, so there's no way for them to see each other. But Iranians can get to Canada, and this library is in Canada. And Iranian students in America can get to this library because this library is also in America.
在美国有许多持单次入境签证的伊朗学生。单次入境意味着如果他们离开，他们不能直接转身重新进入。他们不能回家看望家人。由于旅行禁令，他们的家人不能来这里看望他们，所以他们没有办法见面。但伊朗人可以去加拿大，而这个图书馆在加拿大。在美国的伊朗学生可以到达这个图书馆，因为这个图书馆也属于美国。
So that's what they've been doing, meeting at this library in two countries at once. Yeganeh went up there and waited outside the library on a Saturday morning.
所以这就是他们一直在做的事，在同时属于两个国家的这个图书馆里见面。耶加内去了那里，并在周六早上在图书馆外等候。
Almost immediately, this woman walked in, who herself was an Iranian student. And she was dressed for the winter weather and in a winter coat. And she looked kind of anxious, and I could kind of tell that she's Iranian. And so I started talking to her, and she said that yes, indeed, she was trying to meet her parents.
几乎立刻，一位女士走了进去，她自己也是一名伊朗学生。她穿着冬天的衣服，披着冬大衣。她看起来有点焦虑，我能看出她是伊朗人。所以我开始和她交谈，她说确实，她正试图见她的父母。
They spoke in Persian. Yeganeh is Iranian-American, actually. Her parents came here as students.
他们用波斯语交谈。耶加内其实是伊朗裔美国人。她的父母当年也是作为学生来到这里的。
And I had earlier saw her being questioned by US border patrol agents. And so I asked her what had happened in those interactions because I had heard that border patrol agents were objecting to these reunions and were at times trying to stop people from carrying them out. But she said that they questioned her, they examined her documents, and they asked her if she was here to see her family. And she said yes, and they said great, that's very normal. A lot of people do it. And they let her into the library.
我之前看到她受到美国边境巡逻人员的盘问。所以我问她那些互动中发生了什么，因为我听说边境巡逻人员反对这些团聚，有时试图阻止人们进行这些团聚。但她说他们盘问了她，检查了她的证件，问她是不是来见家人的。她说是的，他们说太好了，这很正常。很多人都这样做。然后他们让她进入了图书馆。
And then maybe about 10, 15 minutes after she first arrived, I kind of hear this bit of commotion. The door of the library is like pretty creaky, and old, and kind of noisy. And these three or four people come in. We were in the second reading room, furthest from the door. And you just see this woman in a headscarf and a winter coat, and she just starts rushing in.
然后可能在她到达后大约10到15分钟，我听到了一点骚动。图书馆的门相当吱呀作响，很旧，有点吵。这三四个人进来了。我们在离门最远的第二阅览室。你只是看到这个戴着头巾、穿着冬大衣的女人，她就开始冲了进来。
And her daughter gets up from the table where I was sitting with her and walks over to her really quickly, and they just embrace. And immediately, tears are flowing. And it's just this really intense and very intimate and private moment. But there was no loud crying. There was no sobbing. There was no loud talking
她的女儿从我和她坐的桌子旁站起来，很快地走过去，他们只是拥抱在一起。立刻，眼泪流了下来。这真的是一个非常强烈、非常亲密和私人的时刻。但没有大声哭泣。没有啜泣。没有大声说话。
Yeah because it's in the library.
是啊，因为是在图书馆里。
[LAUGHS] Yeah. It's just this subdued environment, and they're trying to-- they're both expressing all their emotions, but also trying to fit them into the space.
（笑）是啊。这只是一个低调的环境，他们都在努力——他们都在表达所有的情绪，但也试图把这些情绪塞进这个空间里。
Around this family are kids with headphones on, on computers, parents with kids in the children's reading room. All the library stuff is happening. The librarians stay out of the way, which seems like an acquiescence to these meetings, but there are these new signs up around lately. No eating, no packages, and no family meetings.
在这家人周围，有戴着耳机用电脑的孩子，有带着孩子在儿童阅览室的父母。所有图书馆的事情都在发生。图书管理员待在外面，这似乎是对这些会议的默许，但最近周围有一些新的标志。禁止饮食，禁止包裹，禁止家庭会议。
Yeganeh heard that the US and Canadian authorities had threatened to shut the library down, and she asked them about it. The Canadians denied it. The US had no comment.
耶加内听说美国和加拿大当局威胁要关闭图书馆，她问了他们这件事。加拿大人否认了。美国对此没有置评。
In the library, Yeganeh sees families ignore the signs. This student flew from Michigan. Her family came from Iran for only a few hours together. It seems crazy.
在图书馆里，耶加内看到家人们无视这些标志。这个学生从密歇根州飞过来。她的家人从伊朗过来，只为了在一起几个小时。这看起来太疯狂了。
And then around, I want to say 11:00, another Iranian family entered.
然后大约11点左右，另一个伊朗家庭进来了。
It's been three years since this mother has seen her son. She and her husband come in with their other son, who lives in Canada now. He and his brother look like twins.
这位母亲已经三年没见她的儿子了。她和丈夫带着现在住在加拿大的另一个儿子进来。他和他的兄弟看起来像双胞胎。
These parents have been visiting their son in Canada for weeks. And all this time, they've been trying to figure out, is there any way we can see our other son who lives in Ohio? They couldn't solve it, but just before the parents were scheduled to fly back to Iran, they heard about the library, and everyone rushed there for a few hours.
这些父母在加拿大探望他们的儿子已经几周了。一直以来，他们都在试图弄清楚，有没有什么办法能见到住在俄亥俄州的另一个儿子？他们无法解决这个问题，但就在父母计划飞回伊朗之前，他们听说了这个图书馆，每个人都匆忙赶到那里待了几个小时。
That was also really emotional. I didn't see the exact moment of their embrace, but I saw their goodbye. And that was very difficult to watch.
那也非常感人。我没有看到他们拥抱的确切瞬间，但我看到了他们的告别。那真的很难看下去。
What happened?
发生了什么？
So the brother who's living in the United States, he hugged his mother, and you can just see him sobbing into her shoulder. Then they separate, and she has this very tear-stained face and is putting her coat and scarf back on. And then he hugs his father and, again, buries his face in his shoulder. And the father, I heard him say to his son, take care of yourself. Please take care of yourself.
所以那个住在美国的兄弟，他拥抱了他的母亲，你可以看到他在她肩膀上啜泣。然后他们分开了，她脸上满是泪痕，又穿上外套和头巾。然后他拥抱了他的父亲，再次把脸埋在他肩膀上。父亲，我听到他对儿子说，照顾好自己。请照顾好自己。
A lot of these families talk every day, multiple times a day. Like they know exactly how the other person is doing, what's going on in their life. But still, they fly, rent a car, drive to the border. Shirin Estahbanati, another student, drove up from New York to see her parents who'd flown from Iran. Reuters put up a video of her interview about the visit.
很多这些家庭每天交谈，一天好几次。就像他们完全知道对方过得怎么样，生活中发生了什么。但即使这样，他们还是飞过去，租辆车，开车去边界。希琳·埃斯塔巴纳提，另一个学生，从纽约开车上来见她从伊朗飞来的父母。路透社发布了一段她关于这次访问的采访视频。
Shirin is this glowing, young face. Her emotions are just written right across it. Her dad had had a heart attack recently. She was so anxious to see him.
希琳是一张发光的年轻脸庞。她的情绪直接写在脸上。她的父亲最近心脏病发作了。她非常焦虑地想见他。
I don't know. The time I was just hugging my parents, I was thinking, I wish I could stop all clocks all over the world. I can't explain how tough it was, especially about my dad. I thought even he is shorter than the time I left. I don't know. The time he met me, he started smelling me, and he was like, I miss your smell. So-- [SNIFFLES]
我不知道。我拥抱父母的时候，我想，我希望我能停止全世界所有的时钟。我无法解释那有多艰难，尤其是关于我爸爸。我觉得他甚至比我离开时更矮了。我不知道。他见到我的时候，开始闻我，他说，我想念你的味道。所以——（抽泣）
I'd been thinking of the idea of this show, of libraries as the magical Room of Requirement from Harry Potter. I think this is exactly that. Like imagine these Iranian students in America, thinking, I need a magical place that is somehow in America but also outside it. It seems like an impossible one. It's like a very particular only at this time in America would this exact requirement exist. And a room appeared, a reading room.
我一直在想这个节目的主意，把图书馆看作哈利·波特里神奇的“有求必应屋”。我想这正是那样。就像想象这些在美国的伊朗学生，想着，我需要一个神奇的地方，它在某种程度上在美国，但也在它之外。这看起来是一个不可能的地方。这就像一个非常特别的，只有在此时此地的美国才会存在这样的确切需求。然后一个房间出现了，一个阅览室。
Zoe Chace, who's one of the producers of our show.
佐伊·蔡斯，我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Two, Book Fishing in America. OK, so our program today, of course, is about people who want libraries to satisfy some very deep, and sometimes, very idiosyncratic desires. And the people in this act, they wish for a library that can give them something that only ever existed inside the pages of a book. Sean Cole, tell us what happened.
第二幕，美国的鳟鱼钓鱼。好的，那么我们今天的节目，当然是关于那些想要图书馆满足一些非常深层，有时是非常独特愿望的人们。而这一幕中的人们，他们希望有一个图书馆能给他们一些只存在于书页里的东西。肖恩·科尔，告诉我们发生了什么。
There's this book I've always really loved, a novel by Richard Brautigan. If you haven't heard of him, he was a really funny, almost surreal, hippyish writer in the '60s and '70s, probably best known for the book, Trout Fishing in America, a very short and deeply experimental piece of fiction, part travelogue, part fever dream. It's what made people cultish about Brautigan. A kid who went to my college legally changed his name to Trout Fishing In America.
有一本书我一直非常喜欢，是理查德·布劳提根的一本小说。如果你没听说过他，他在60、70年代是一位非常有趣、近乎超现实的嬉皮风格作家，可能最出名的是《在美国钓鳟鱼》这本书，这是一部非常简短且深入实验性的虚构作品，既是游记又是发烧梦。这使得人们对布劳提根产生了一种狂热。一个去我大学的学生合法地把自己的名字改成了“在美国钓鳟鱼”。
But the novel I'm talking about is lesser known. It's called The Abortion, subtitle, An Historical Romance 1966. And it's not so much the story that gets me. It's the setting. It takes place in a library in San Francisco. But instead of coming to take books out of the library, people come to submit unpublished books they've written to the library, forever.
但我谈论的那本小说不太出名。它叫《堕胎》，副标题，1966年的历史浪漫史。吸引我的不是故事本身，而是背景。它发生在这个旧金山的一家图书馆里。但人们不是来从图书馆借书的，而是来向图书馆提交他们写过的未出版的书，永远存留。
The books are there to stay. They can bring a book in anytime. The library never closes. And the librarian-- there is only one-- is always there to greet them. He lives at the library, and he's the narrator of the story.
这些书会一直留在那里。他们可以随时带一本书来。图书馆从不关门。而图书管理员——只有一个——总是在那里迎接他们。他住在图书馆，是故事的叙述者。
This is from the first chapter. The librarian says, "We don't use the Dewey decimal classification or any index system to keep track of our books. We record their entrance into the library in the Library Contents Ledger, and then we give the book back to its author, who is free to place it anywhere he wants in the library, on whatever shelf catches his fancy.
这是第一章的内容。图书管理员说：“我们不使用杜威十进制分类法或任何索引系统来记录我们的书。我们把它们进入图书馆的情况记录在图书馆内容账本里，然后把书还给作者，他们可以自由地把它放在图书馆的任何地方，放在任何他们喜欢的架子上。”
It doesn't make any difference where a book is placed because nobody ever checks them out and nobody ever comes here to read them. This is not that kind of library. This is another kind of library."
“书放在哪里并没有什么区别，因为从来没有人借阅，也从来没有人来这里阅读。这不是那种类型的图书馆。这是另一种类型的图书馆。”
The librarian is reflexively polite and effusive. He might say to someone, "I don't think we have a book like this in the entire library. This is a first." He puts people at ease. He says, "My clothes are not expensive but they are friendly and neat and my human presence is welcoming."
图书管理员是反射性地礼貌和热情的。他可能会对某人说：“我不认为整个图书馆里有这样的书。这还是第一次。”他让人感到轻松。他说：“我的衣服不贵，但很友好、整洁，我的人存在感很受欢迎。”
Eventually, a woman comes in with a book, and she's very beautiful. They fall in love. She gets pregnant, but they're not ready to have a child. So because this takes place in 1966, the two of them travel to Mexico to get an abortion, which is why the novel is called The Abortion. But just the spectacle of this library, it's hilarious, and heartbreaking, and democratic, and other-dimensional all at the same time.
最终，一个女人带着一本书进来了，她非常漂亮。他们坠入爱河。她怀孕了，但他们还没准备好要孩子。因为故事发生在1966年，他们两人去墨西哥堕胎，这就是小说叫《堕胎》的原因。但仅仅是这个图书馆的景象，它既滑稽、令人心碎、民主，又同时具有异维感。
Brautigan imagined a great anonymous wash of humanity marching through, with a lot on its mind. Kind of the Utopian ideal of the public square, except completely silent, all written down on rows and rows of unread books. The librarian says the main purpose of the library is, quote, "to gather pleasantly together the unwanted, the lyrical and haunted volumes of American writing." And when you talk to other people who've read The Abortion, the conversation usually winds its way to this one chapter.
布劳提根想象着一大群无名的人走过，脑子里装着很多事。这算是一种乌托邦式的公共广场理想，除了完全安静之外，一切都写在一行行未读的书里。图书管理员说图书馆的主要目的是，引用，“愉快地收集那些不想要的、抒情的、被困扰的美国文学作品。”当你和其他读过《堕胎》的人交谈时，谈话通常会引向这一章。
"The 23?"
“第23个？”
"The 23." [LAUGHS]
“第23个。”（笑）
Yeah.
是啊。
This is Todd Lockwood, a photographer and music producer in Burlington, Vermont. I'll tell you why I got in touch with him in a minute. "The 23" is essentially a list of all 23 books that came into the library this one particular day, by little kids, old people. And the chapter's made up of just little descriptions of the 23 books that the librarian wrote down in his ledger.
这是托德·洛克伍德，佛蒙特州伯灵顿的摄影师和音乐制作人。我稍后会告诉你我为什么联系他。“第23个”本质上是那天进入图书馆的所有23本书的清单，由小孩、老人创作。这一章就是由图书管理员记录在账本里的那23本书的小小描述组成的。
There's one called It's the Queen of Darkness, Pal, a science fiction novel written by sewer worker. There's a book called Leather Clothes and the History of Man, which is somehow entirely made of leather. Not just the binding, but the pages. Richard Brautigan himself comes into the library with a book called Moose. And a doctor comes in looking, quote, "doctory and very nervous," with a book entitled The Need for Legalized Abortion.
有一本叫《它是黑暗女王，伙计》，是一位下水道工人写的科幻小说。有一本叫《皮革衣服与人类历史》，不知何故完全是由皮革制成的。不仅是装订，页面也是。理查德·布劳提根自己带着一本叫《驼鹿》的书进来了。一位医生走了进来，看起来“很有医生味，非常紧张”，带着一本题为《合法堕胎的必要性》的书。
I asked Todd what some of his favorites were, and he pointed to this one.
我问托德他最喜欢哪些，他指了指这一本。
Just the title alone is just wonderful. It's called Bacon Death by Marcia Patterson. "The author was a totally nondescript young woman except for the look of anguish on her face. She handed me this fantastically greasy book and fled the library in terror. The book actually looked like a pound of bacon. I was going to open it and see what it was about, but I changed my mind. I didn't know whether to fry the book or put it on the shelf.
仅仅是标题就非常棒。它叫《培根之死》，作者是玛西娅·帕特森。“作者除了脸上带着痛苦的神情外，完全是一个不起眼的年轻女子。她递给我这本非常油腻的书，然后惊恐地逃离了图书馆。书看起来真的像一磅培根。我本来打算打开看看是关于什么的，但我改变了主意。我不知道是该把这本书炸了还是放回架子上。”
Being a librarian here is sometimes a challenge."
“在这里当图书管理员有时是一种挑战。”
Todd first read The Abortion when it came out in the early '70s. A friend of his gave it to him with a little inscription that said, "This book will change your life."
托德在70年代初《堕胎》出版时第一次读到它。他的一个朋友送给他，并题写了一句：“这本书会改变你的人生。”
And that turned out to be more than prophetic.
事实证明这不仅仅是预言。
He ended up reading it about once a year for the next 15 years.
在接下来的15年里，他每年大约读一遍。
And every time I'd read it, I'd get the same feeling from it. First thing I would say to myself is, when is somebody going to build this library? When is somebody going to do this? To eventually becoming, when am I going to do this?
每次读它，我都会有同样的感觉。首先我会对自己说，什么时候会有人建造这个图书馆？什么时候会有人做这件事？最终变成了，我什么时候去做这件事？
A real life library for unpublished books submitted by their authors. A home for anything anyone felt a burning need to express, or explain, or somehow get off their chests. Todd dreamed for years about one day creating a place like that. And there was clearly a desire for it.
一个为作者提交的未出版书籍提供的真实生活图书馆。一个为任何人感到有强烈表达、解释或以某种方式倾诉的冲动而提供的家。托德梦想着有一天创造这样一个地方。而且显然有这种需求。
In The Abortion, Brautigan gives an address for his fictional library. 3150 Sacramento Street, San Francisco, California, 94115, which is the real life address of the Presidio branch of the San Francisco Public Library. So for a while, people were actually sending their unpublished manuscripts there and had to be informed, this is not that kind of library. This is a normal kind of library
在《堕胎》中，布劳提根为他虚构的图书馆给出了地址。加利福尼亚州旧金山萨克拉门托街3150号，94115，这是旧金山公共图书馆普雷西迪奥分馆的真实地址。所以有一段时间，人们真的把他们未出版的手稿寄到那里，不得不被通知：这不是那种图书馆。这是一个正常的图书馆。
Anyway, Todd kept putting off his dream, thinking, I'll put that library together someday. And then two things happened, the first one being very tragic.
不管怎样，托德一直搁置他的梦想，想着，总有一天我会把那个图书馆建起来。然后发生了两件事，第一件事非常悲惨。
My sister died in a plane crash--
我妹妹在一次空难中去世了——
Oh, my God.
噢，天哪。
--in 1989. This was the United DC-10 that went down in Sioux City, Iowa. So losing a sibling is one of those things that really causes you to look at the things that you've done in your life and ask yourself, are these really the best things I can be doing right now? And so at any rate, about a month and a half or two months after the crash, I thought, you know what? I need to just get away from this constant sorrow here and take myself to the movies.
——在1989年。这是联合航空DC-10客机在爱荷华州苏城坠毁的事件。所以失去一个亲人是那种真正让你审视自己生活中所做的事情并问自己，这些真的是我现在能做的最好的事情吗？无论如何，在坠机事件发生一个月半或两个月后，我想，你知道吗？我需要摆脱这里持续的悲伤，去看看电影。
And there was this movie that had come out earlier that year that Todd hadn't seen yet, a Kevin Costner vehicle about an Iowa farmer who plows up his corn to build a baseball diamond.
那年早些时候出了一部电影，托德还没看过，是一部凯文·科斯特纳主演的关于一位爱荷华州农民犁掉玉米地来建造棒球场的电影。
(WHISPERING) If you build it, he will come.
（耳语）如果你建造它，他就会来。
[RUSTLING]
（沙沙声）
So I went to see Field of Dreams, and about halfway into that film, it became really obvious to me that Brautigan's library is my baseball field. If I build it, people will come.
所以我就去看了《梦幻之地》，大约看了这部电影的一半，对我来说很明显，布劳提根的图书馆就是我的棒球场。如果我建造它，人们就会来。
It wasn't even before the movie was over that that struck you?
甚至在电影结束之前你就有这种感觉了吗？
Yeah. Yeah, as soon as that part of the film started to unfold, I was just astounded at the parallel. I was like, this is weird. I felt literally as if I'm supposed to be sitting here right now watching this. This is all part of a big plan.
是啊。是啊，当电影的那部分开始展开时，我惊讶于这种相似性。我想，这太奇怪了。我真的感觉就像我此时此刻应该坐在这里看电影一样。这一切都是宏大计划的一部分。
Which, if you remember, is exactly the way Kevin Costner's character felt in the movie.
这和你记得凯文·科斯特纳的角色在电影里的感觉完全一样。
And I'm not a person that gets too caught up in the metaphysical aspects of life. But when I stepped outside the theater afterward, I just--
而且我不是一个会被生活中的形而上学方面吸引的人。但当我看完电影走出影院时，我只是——
I feel it as strongly as I've ever felt anything in my life.
我感受到了我一生中感受到的最强烈的力量。
I'd never felt so sure about anything in my life.
我这辈子从来没有对任何事情如此确定过。
Todd immediately started calling around, putting a board of advisors together, appealing for funding. It took about half a year. And then finally--
托德立即开始四处打电话，组建顾问委员会，呼吁资助。大约花了一年时间。然后终于——
And around here on the side is our entrance.
在这边旁边是我们的入口。
--the library opened its doors in Burlington, Vermont in 1990. This tape is from a BBC Radio story that aired a few years in. Todd led the producers past The Vermont Institute of Massage Therapy--
——图书馆于1990年在佛蒙特州伯灵顿开了门。这段录音来自BBC广播的故事，几年前播出的。托德带领制作人走过佛蒙特州按摩治疗学院——
And here we are.
我们到了。
--to a modest wooden building, outfitted with comfy chairs and shelves for the books. A swinging placard out front said, in capital letters--
——来到一栋简陋的木质建筑，配备了舒适的椅子和书架。前面的摇摆招牌上用大写字母写着——
The Brautigan Library.
布劳提根图书馆。
And underneath that, the words, "A Very Public Library."
下面写着，“一个非常公共的图书馆。”
[DOOR CLOSING]
（关门声）
Now it's one thing to adapt a piece of fiction into a movie. It's another thing to adapt a piece of fiction into a library. As soon as they started talking about how The Brautigan Library would work in real life, Todd and his advisors and volunteers realized that they were going to need to make some concessions, such as whereas in the novel, there's just one librarian, in real life, there were many. All volunteer, and none of them lived there. Certainly never impregnated anyone there, or not to Todd's knowledge.
现在，把一部虚构作品改编成电影是一回事。把一部虚构作品改编成图书馆是另一回事。当他们开始讨论布劳提根图书馆如何在现实生活中运作时，托德和他的顾问以及志愿者意识到他们将不得不做出一些让步，比如在小说中，只有一个图书管理员，而在现实生活中，有很多。全是志愿者，没人住在那里。当然，没人 impregnation 任何人，或者至少托德不知道。
And unlike in the novel, the books were almost exclusively submitted by mail. And the authors had to kick in a little money, $25 or so, to cover the cost of binding their manuscripts. And people actually came to read the books, from all over the country.
而且不像小说里，书几乎全是邮寄提交的。作者必须付一点钱，大约25美元，来支付装订手稿的费用。而且人们真的从全国各地来阅读这些书。
I was sitting there one day, and a couple comes in the front door. And they announce, we're here! And I said, well, welcome. Where are you from? And this couple had flown from Houston for the weekend, specifically to hang out in The Brautigan Library for a couple of days.
有一天我坐在那里，一对夫妇走进来。他们宣布，我们来了！我说，欢迎。你们从哪来？这对夫妇特意从休斯顿飞来过周末，就是为了在布劳提根图书馆泡两天。
Stop it.
别说了。
And we had many of those.
我们有很多那样的客户。
Probably because of the barrage of media stories about the library. New York Times, Wall Street Journal, a wire story that got picked up by hundreds of papers across the country. Everyone treated it as a quirky human interest story. The first and, at the time, only library for unpublished books, which started off as a piece of make-believe in a weirdo novel written 20 years beforehand.
可能是因为关于这个图书馆的媒体报道狂潮。《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》，一篇被全国数百家报纸转载的电讯报道。每个人都把它当作一个古怪的人文趣事。第一个，也是当时唯一的未出版书籍图书馆，它始于20年前一本怪异小说中的幻想。
There was a ledger the librarians used, but they didn't write down descriptions of the books that came in. Rather they wrote down descriptions of the people that came in. This is from that BBC story.
图书馆员用过一个账本，但他们没有记录进入的书的描述。相反，他们记录了进入的人的描述。这是BBC故事里的内容。
This is March 20, '93. "A man stopped by from Washington. 'Is this the library?' he asked. 'Yes,' I said. 'It's The Brautigan.' 'What's a Brautigan? Is it the city library?' I told him it was a home for unpublished manuscripts.
这是93年3月20日。“一个华盛顿来的男人顺道经过。‘这是图书馆吗？’他问。‘是的，’我说。‘这是布劳提根图书馆。’‘布劳提根是什么？是市立图书馆吗？’我告诉他这是一个未出版手稿的家。”
'Why?' he asked. 'So they can stay alive, and people can read them,' I said. He wasn't impressed. 'Where's the real library?' he wanted to know. 'Same street, three blocks up.' He left."
“‘为什么？’他问。‘这样它们就能活着，人们也能读到它们，’我说。他没被打动。‘真正的图书馆在哪里？’他想知道。‘在同一条街，再往上走三个街区。’他走了。”
A lot of people have asked that question-- why? And over the years, Todd has tended to give a pretty short and well-honed answer, almost like an artist statement. In fact, he used almost exactly the same words with the BBC producers in 1993, as he did with me in 2018.
很多人问过那个问题——为什么？多年来，托德倾向于给出一个非常简短且精炼的回答，几乎像一份艺术家声明。事实上，他用的措辞和1993年BBC制作人交谈时几乎一模一样，和他2018年对我说的也是。
The beauty of it is that it doesn't make sense.
它的美妙之处在于它说不通。
For me, one of the beauties of this whole thing was that it didn't make any sense.
对我来说，这一切美妙之处在于它根本说不通。
It was illogical.
这不合逻辑。
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
Just like in Field of Dreams, where he says, I have done something completely illogical.
就像在《梦幻之地》里，他说，我做了一些完全不合逻辑的事情。
Right. Right. Oh, yeah.
对。对。哦，是啊。
I have just created something totally illogical.
我刚刚创造了一些完全不合逻辑的东西。
That's what I like about it.
这就是我喜欢它的地方。
It's what I liked about Todd's library, and it's what I'd always loved about the library in the novel, the fictional one. It wasn't just illogical. It was impossible. And I loved sitting with the librarian in that impossible place, surrounded by books that only he and the people who wrote them knew about.
这也是我喜欢托德图书馆的地方，也是我一直喜欢小说中那个虚构图书馆的地方。它不仅是不合逻辑的。它是不可思议的。我喜欢和图书管理员坐在这个不可思议的地方，被只有他本人和作者才知道的书籍包围。
So for someone to transform an imaginary magical place I loved into an actual location I could maybe visit one day, it was like finding out there was a real life chocolate factory, like the one Charlie visited, or a wardrobe that opened up unto a forest with talking animals in it.
所以对于某人来说，能把我喜欢的一个虚构的神奇地方变成一个我有一天可能访问的实际地点，就像发现了一个像查理参观过的那个真实的巧克力工厂，或者一个通往有会说话动物的森林的衣柜。
But there was something else, something stranger, that The Brautigan Library had in common with Field of Dreams. The story goes like this. In 1991, about a year after the library opened, the Bumbershoot Arts Festival in Seattle asked Todd if he wanted to set up a mini version of the library at the festival, an exhibit. So Todd, his wife, and about 100 of the books they'd amassed up to that point got on a plane, flew out there, and set up shop in this indoor event space.
但还有别的事情，更奇怪的事情，布劳提根图书馆和《梦幻之地》有共同点。故事是这样的。1991年，在图书馆开业一年左右，西雅图的Bumbershoot艺术节问托德是否想在艺术节上设置一个图书馆的微型版本，一个展览。所以托德、他的妻子，以及他们当时收集的大约100本书上了飞机，飞了过去，在这个室内活动空间摆开了摊位。
And so first day at the exhibit, I'm showing people around. And this gentleman walks up to me, and puts out his hand, and says, Hi, I'm Bill Kinsella, the author of Shoeless Joe, the book Field of Dreams was based on.
展览的第一天，我带大家参观。这位绅士走过来，伸出手说，嗨，我是比尔·金塞拉，《赤脚男孩》的作者，这部书就是《梦幻之地》的基础。
No way. No way.
没可能。没可能。
And I was just dumbfounded. I said, you have no idea how wildly fantastic it is that you are here right now. I said, if you hadn't have written that, I might never have stepped up to the plate and really done this.
我当时惊呆了。我说，你根本不知道你现在出现在这里是多么疯狂和美妙。我说，如果你没写那本书，我可能永远不会上场，真的做成这件事。
You just said, "stepped up to the plate."
你刚才说了，“上场”。
Oh. [LAUGHS]
哦。（笑）
It just so happened that Bill Kinsella, or WP Kinsella is what it says on his book jackets, was a featured speaker at Bumbershoot that year.
恰巧比尔·金塞拉，或者他的书封上写的WP金塞拉，是那年Bumbershoot的特邀演讲嘉宾。
And he said, well. He said, I've got one for you. Were it not for Richard Brautigan, I would never have written that book.
他说，好吧。他说，我也有一件事要告诉你。如果不是因为理查德·布劳提根，我就永远不会写那本书。
No way.
没可能。
In fact, he said I would never have gotten into being a fiction writer, were it not for Richard Brautigan.
事实上，他说如果不是因为理查德·布劳提根，我就永远不会成为一名小说家。
This is the part of the story that when I tell it to people, their eyes get really wide. The part where one twin in a fairy tale figures out why she's been wearing half a locket around her neck the entire time. Todd hadn't known it, but no other writer had as much of an impact on Kinsella's life and career as Richard Brautigan.
这就是故事里当我讲给别人听时，他们的眼睛睁得很大的那部分。童话里的双胞胎之一弄明白她为什么一直戴着半个项坠的那部分。托德并不知道，但没有其他作家像理查德·布劳提根那样对比尔·金塞拉的生活和职业产生过如此巨大的影响。
In 1985, Kinsella published a book of weird, vignettey short stories that he called his Brautigans. He dedicated the collection to Richard Brautigan, including, in the dedication, a fan letter he'd written to Brautigan, in which he said, quote, "I have just written a novel about a man who drives from Iowa to New Hampshire, kidnaps JD Salinger, and takes him to a baseball game at Fenway Park. He was talking about Shoeless Joe. That was part of the plot.
1985年，金塞拉出版了一本奇怪的短篇小品集，他称之为他的“布劳提根集”。他把这部集子献给了理查德·布劳提根，并在献词中引用了他写给布劳提根的一封粉丝信，信中说，引用，“我刚刚写了一部小说，关于一个男人从爱荷华州开车到新罕布什尔州，绑架了JD·塞林格，带他去芬威公园看棒球比赛。”他指的是《赤脚男孩》。那是情节的一部分。
And so you're both kind of shocked. I'm imagining two shocked men.
所以你们两个都有点震惊。我想象着两个震惊的男人。
Yeah, right. [LAUGHING] I was like, perhaps someway or other, Brautigan himself is playing some sort of role in all this. That we're like marionettes, and he's up there just with a great big smile on his face, just having a blast, messing with the real world.
是啊，对。（大笑）我想，也许以某种方式，布劳提根本身在这一切中扮演了某种角色。就像我们是木偶，而他在上面脸上挂着灿烂的笑容，玩得很开心，干预着现实世界。
Or haunting it somehow, like he was saying, playfully, better not forget me. I wanted to talk with Bill Kinsella for this story, but he died in 2016 on September 16, the same day Richard Brautigan had died in 1984. Both of them chose that day to end their lives. Kinsella was terminally ill and opted for doctor-assisted suicide, which is legal now in Canada, where he's from. Brautigan shot himself with a revolver.
或者是某种程度上缠绕着它，就像他在说，顽皮地，最好别忘了我。我本来想和比尔·金塞拉谈谈这个故事，但他于2016年9月16日去世了，和理查德·布劳提根在1984年去世的同一天。他们两人都选择了那一天结束自己的生命。金塞拉身患绝症，选择了医生协助自杀，这在他家乡加拿大现在是合法的。布劳提根用左轮手枪自杀了。
The Brautigan Library chugged along in its original location for about six years. But as Todd once wrote in an issue of the library newsletter, reality can be so clankingly real at times. By 1996, fewer and fewer manuscripts were coming in. Money was tight. Here and there, Todd had to make ends meet with funds from his own bank account.
布劳提根图书馆在原址磕磕绊绊经营了大约六年。但正如托德曾在图书馆时事通讯的一期中写的那样，现实有时是非常真实的。到1996年，提交的手稿越来越少。资金紧张。托德不得不从自己的银行账户里拿出钱来维持收支平衡。
And finally, the entire Brautigan Library was moved to a room in the Fletcher Free Library, the regular public library down the road in Burlington. It stopped accepting new books but people could still come and read the ones that existed. 10 years went by, and then the Fletcher Library decided it needed the space for other things. So all The Brautigan Library books, more than 300 of them, found themselves shrink wrapped on a wooden pallet in Todd Lockwood's basement.
最后，整个布劳提根图书馆搬到了伯灵顿路下的常规公共图书馆——弗莱彻免费图书馆的一间屋子里。它停止接受新书，但人们仍然可以来阅读现有的书籍。10年过去了，然后弗莱彻图书馆决定需要这些空间做其他事情。所以所有的布劳提根图书馆书籍，超过300本，发现自己被收缩膜包裹着，放在托德·洛克伍德地下室的一个木托盘上。
And this is the moment in the library's history when I first heard about it. I've been wanting to tell this story and see the books for myself for about 10 years. But way back when Todd and I started talking about this, he said he needed to wait, that he was in negotiations with a couple of academic libraries that might be interested, couldn't do an interview until something was finalized, et cetera and so on. Certainly the books weren't available to look at. I said I'd keep checking in, but I didn't.
这就是图书馆历史中我第一次听说它的时刻。我想讲述这个故事并亲自看书已经大约10年了。但当托德和我开始谈论这件事时，他说他需要等待，他正在与几家可能感兴趣的学术图书馆谈判，在某些事情敲定之前不能接受采访，等等。当然，书也无法查看。我说我会保持跟进，但我没有。
And then this past summer, I started thinking about the library again. So I looked it up, and the library had finally found a new home in Vancouver, Washington, about 3,000 miles away from where it was born.
然后去年夏天，我开始再次想到这个图书馆。于是我查了一下，图书馆终于在华盛顿州温哥华找到了一个新家，距离它出生地约3000英里。
Watch your head here, low ceiling.
这里小心头，天花板很低。
And it had a new librarian, John Barber, a professor at one of the universities in town. He led me down into the basement of the Clark County Historical Museum.
而且它有了一位新的图书管理员，约翰·巴伯，镇上一所大学的教授。他带着我走进了克拉克县历史博物馆的地下室。
And here it is, The Brautigan Library.
这儿就是了，布劳提根图书馆。
Wow.
哇。
These are all the manuscripts.
这些全都是手稿。
Oh, my gosh.
天哪。
Come to find, the manuscripts have been housed in this building since 2010, and John Barber was instrumental in making that happen. If there's such a thing as a Brautigan scholar, it's him. He may know more about Richard Brautigan than anyone else alive. He was a student of Brautigan's and hung out with him.
原来，手稿自2010年起就存放在这栋建筑里，约翰·巴伯在实现这一过程中发挥了重要作用。如果说有布劳提根学者，那就是他。他可能比任何在世的人都更了解理查德·布劳提根。他曾是布劳提根的学生，和他一起玩过。
So naturally, he was a big supporter of the library from early on. And when the library shut down, he was sad to think of all the books being mothballed in Todd's basement. Until finally, he just got inspired and organized to have them all moved to this place. And he's taken on the mantle of the librarian.
所以自然地，他很早就成了图书馆的大力支持者。当图书馆关闭时，他很难过地想到所有的书都会被丢在托德的地下室里吃灰。直到最后，他受到了启发，组织把它们全部搬到了这里。他也承担起了图书管理员的职责。
Also, I should say, Richard Brautigan once told me that he would haunt me.
还有，我应该说，理查德·布劳提根曾经告诉我他会缠着我。
Wait, he said, I will haunt you?
等等，他说，我会缠着你？
Yes.
是的。
This was in 1982, two years before Brautigan killed himself. Brautigan's friend, Nikki Arai, had just died of complications from cancer.
这是在1982年，布劳提根自杀前两年。布劳提根的朋友尼基·阿莱刚刚因癌症并发症去世。
And I said, you have your memories of her. You could write about those memories. You're a writer. That's what you do. And he said, I don't write for therapy, and actually got really upset with me. Then he said, but then again-- and he turned and walked away. And he came back after a few minutes with a little slip of paper, on which he had written, "Where you are now, I will join you soon."
我说，你有关于她的记忆。你可以写下那些记忆。你是作家。那就是你做的事。他说，我不为了治疗写作，实际上对我非常生气。然后他说，但转念一想——他转身走开了。几分钟后他回来拿着一张小纸条，上面写着：“你在哪里，我很快就会加入你。”
After dinner and another bottle of whiskey, they went out to the yard and burned the note in a kind of ritual to send those words to Brautigan's friend.
晚饭和另一瓶威士忌之后，他们去院子里烧掉了纸条，作为一种仪式，把那些话送给布劳提根的朋友。
And I went home that night-- slowly because of all the whiskey-- and wrote about that experience. And I showed it to him, and he said, if you ever show this to anybody before I'm dead, I will haunt you. And I did. And he does.
那天晚上我回家了——因为喝了太多威士忌而走得很慢——并写下了那次经历。我给他看了，他说，如果你在我死前把这个给任何人看，我会缠着你。我看了。他缠着我。
After all, John, for all intents and purposes, now inhabits a physical manifestation of an idea Brautigan had in his head. And what's a little startling when you meet John is that he is the librarian from the novel. Like he's just like him. His clothes are not expensive but friendly and neat, and his human presence welcoming.
毕竟，约翰，出于所有意图和目的，现在居住在布劳提根脑中构想的一个想法的物理表现中。当你见到约翰时，有点令人震惊的是，他就是小说里的图书管理员。他和他简直一模一样。他的衣服不贵，但友好、整洁，他的人存在感很受欢迎。
Yes, we look an awful lot alike. Tall, mustache, glasses.
是的，我们看起来非常像。高个子、胡子、眼镜。
He's reflexively polite and effusive. I had all three meals with him the day we spent together. And each time, he said to the server, in all earnestness, "Thank you for your hospitality." Same as when the museum's director let us in early before it opened.
他反射性地礼貌且热情。我们在一起度过的那天，我和他一起吃了三顿饭。每次他都真诚地对服务员说：“谢谢你的款待。”当博物馆馆长在开门前让我们提早进去时也是一样。
Thanks so much for accommodating us.
非常感谢你们照顾我们。
Of course.
当然。
Thanks.
谢谢。
It's much smaller than I imagined somehow.
不知为何，它比我想象的要小得多。
Well, there's that, certainly. There's 300-plus manuscripts that are associated with the library. So we might actually say that it's small but mighty. Because each of these 300-plus manuscripts that we're standing in the middle of has dreams, and aspirations, memories, and hopes for the future associated with it.
嗯，确实如此。有300多份手稿与图书馆相关。所以我们可能实际上说它小而强大。因为我们站在中间的这300多份手稿中的每一份，都承载着梦想、抱负、记忆和对未来的希望。
In fact, it's just two long sets of bookshelves at one end of the museum's research library. And all of the books have the same plain black, brown, gray, or blue bindings. The host of that BBC piece said they looked like body bags for whatever was inside of them. I really wonder how many of them were ever read cover to cover.
事实上，它只是博物馆研究图书馆末端的两排长书架。所有的书都有相同的普通黑色、棕色、灰色或蓝色装订。BBC报道的那位主持人说它们看起来像是里面东西的尸袋。我真的很想知道有多少书被从头到尾读过。
I wanted to see if being in the library gave me the same feeling I had as when I read The Abortion. And I have to say more and more, it really did feel like I had climbed into the pages of that novel, with its messy expanse of humanity marching through. Some of the books were silly. Others were mournfully nostalgic. Still others were deadly serious.
我想看看身处图书馆是否给了我读《堕胎》时的同样感觉。我不得不说，确实越来越感觉好像我爬进了那本小说的页面，看着凌乱的人群走过。有些书很愚蠢。另一些则带有悲伤的怀旧感。还有一些则是死气沉沉的认真。
Enjoy the War, Peace will be Terrible.
《享受战争，和平会很糟糕》。
Which is about the lives of two teen girls in World War II Vienna. Others promoted radical ideas.
这是关于二战维也纳两名少女的生活。另一些书宣传激进的想法。
Three Essays Advocating the Abolishing of Money.
《倡导废除货币的三篇文章》。
Almost 50 poetry collections. I opened up one called I'd Be Your Roadkill, Baby. The poetry reading.
近50本诗集。我打开了一本叫《宝贝，我愿做你的路杀》。诗歌朗诵。
"He greased me with his words--" oh! OK, I can't say that on the radio.
“他用言语润滑了我——”噢！好吧，我不能在广播里说这个。
Instead of using Dewey Decimal, the books are organized according to what they call the Mayonnaise System. It's a Brautigan in-joke. He ended Trout Fishing in America with the word "mayonnaise." And it goes by category. So there's adventure, family, future, humor, love, meaning of life, poetry, natural world, social political cultural, spirituality, street life, war and peace, and my favorite, all the rest.
书不是用杜威十进制法组织的，而是按照他们所谓的“蛋黄酱系统”组织的。这是布劳提根的一个内部笑话。他以“蛋黄酱”这个词结束了《在美国钓鳟鱼》。它是按类别组织的。所以有探险、家庭、未来、幽默、爱情、人生意义、诗歌、自然世界、社会政治文化、灵性、街头生活、战争与和平，以及我最喜欢的，其余所有。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
There's always the miscellaneous drawer, right? Where something is just too offbeat to fit in.
总有一个杂项抽屉，对吧？当某样东西太不常规，放不进去时。
And instead of the summaries being in a big library contents ledger, there's a summary printed out on the first page of each book. Of course, almost all of the books are offbeat. Like this is the summary of a novel called Did She Leave Me Any Money?
而且总结不是写在一个大图书馆内容账本里，每一本书的第一页都印有总结。当然，几乎所有的书都是不常规的。比如这是一本叫《她给我留钱了吗？》的小说的总结。
It says, "A philosophical comedy about men, money, motivation, winning strategies, architecture, nudism, trucking, corporate assassinations, heart attacks, sexual politics, hometown parades, spiritual warriors, and the dredging of Willapa Bay."
上面写着，“一部关于男人、金钱、动机、获胜策略、建筑、裸体主义、卡车运输、企业暗杀、心脏病发作、性政治、家乡游行、精神勇士和威拉帕湾疏浚的哲学喜剧。”
This is something a bunch of the books have in common. It's like their authors are gushing forth with everything they've been wanting to talk about their whole lives. And with a lot of them, there's this sense of, this is important. I alone have the answer. Just like with a lot of the books in Brautigan's novel. For instance, there's the most prolific contributor to The Brautigan Library, Albert E. Helzner.
这是很多书共有的东西。就像它们的作者在倾泻他们一生想谈论的一切。对于其中很多，有一种感觉，这很重要。只有我一个人有答案。就像布劳提根小说里的很多书一样。例如，布劳提根图书馆最丰富的投稿人，阿尔伯特·E·赫尔兹纳。
He's got 19 books here, three under an assumed name. And they're mostly comprised of his own personal scientific theories and observations. Titles like A Revolutionary Way of Looking at the Earth as a Planet, or, more to the point, The World is Wrong. The only way I can think to describe it-- and I do so admiringly-- it's like PhD-level stoner thinking. Everything and everyone in the Helzner-verse is interconnected and impactful.
他这里有19本书，三本用了化名。它们大多由他个人的科学理论和观察组成。书名如《观察地球作为行星的一种革命性方式》，或者更直截了当的，《世界错了》。我能想到的描述它的唯一方式——我怀着钦佩的心情——就像博士水平的吸毒者思考。赫尔兹纳宇宙中的一切和每个人都是相互关联且有影响力的。
In his book, October 6, 1990, Helzner said that every year on October 6, he'd go to the maternity ward of a hospital, look at a newborn baby through the glass, and ask himself, how did this birth come about? What is the long-range effect? And what is the significance of any birth? Addressing the baby he went to see in 1990, he says he wants to tell her what transpired on the day before she was born.
在他的书《1990年10月6日》中，赫尔兹纳说，每年10月6日，他都会去医院的产房，透过玻璃看一个新生儿，问自己，这个出生是怎么来的？长期影响是什么？任何出生的意义是什么？对他在1990年去看的那个婴儿说话，他说他想告诉她她出生前一天发生的事情。
"I spent the whole day thinking about you," he writes. "On that day, the moon was shining on my town of Marblehead, Massachusetts. It was a bright full moon sitting in a clear sky. My wife and I drove to Seaside 5 Corners for a bite to eat. We saw the moon as we drove along. We saw the old buildings. You'll see the same moon and the same old buildings when you grow up."
“我花了一整天时间想着你，”他写道。“那天，月亮照耀着我的马萨诸塞州马布尔黑德镇。那是一个明亮的满月，挂在晴朗的天空中。我和妻子开车去海边5街角吃点东西。我们开车时看到了月亮。我们看到了古老的建筑。等你长大后，你会看到同样的月亮和同样的古老建筑。”
Albert Helzner died in June 2016, but his books are still at the library. God knows where that baby is now.
阿尔伯特·赫尔兹纳于2016年6月去世，但他的书还在图书馆。天知道那个孩子现在在哪里。
I asked John if there were any books in particular that he wanted to show me. And he was really enthusiastic about this one that he thought gave a sense of what the library was there for. It's called--
我问约翰是否有特别想让我看的书。他非常热情地谈到了这本他认为能让人理解图书馆存在意义的书。它叫——
Autobiography about a Nobody. And it's written by Etherley Murray of Pittman, New Jersey. And she may have said, oh look, here's a library that accepts manuscripts, regardless of subject matter.
《关于无名小卒的自传》。它是新泽西州皮特曼的埃瑟利·默里写的。她可能说过，哦看，这里有一个接受手稿的图书馆，不论主题是什么。
Right, exactly.
对，没错。
I'm a nobody. They'll be interested.
我是无名小卒。他们会感兴趣的。
It's mainly the story of her growing up during the Depression in Altoona, Pennsylvania, eating onion sandwiches and, quote, "wearing coats that belonged to women who had just departed this life." Except it was in the humor section, intentionally so. There's a cartoon horse in a red union suit on the title page, tears cascading from behind its blinders.
它主要讲述了她在宾夕法尼亚州阿尔图纳经济大萧条时期成长的故事，吃着洋葱三明治，“穿着属于那些刚刚离开人世的女人的外套。”只是它是在幽默部分，特意如此。标题页上有一个穿着红色连体裤的卡通马，眼罩后泪水倾泻而下。
She says, in the notes that came along with the submission, that she had submitted it to 40 publishers, who, although they liked the story, did not publish manuscripts of nobodies.
她在提交随附的说明中说，她曾将它提交给40家出版社，尽管他们喜欢这个故事，但他们不出版无名小卒的手稿。
In Brautigan's novel, a guy in his 50s walks into the library with a book he wrote when he was 17. "'This book has set the world's record for rejections,' he says. 'It has been rejected 459 times, and now I am an old man.'"
在布劳提根的小说里，一个50多岁的男人拿着他17岁时写的一本书走进图书馆。“‘这本书创下了拒绝的世界纪录，’他说。‘它被拒绝了459次，现在我是一个老人了。’”
You know, there'd be a sense of completion, for one thing.
你知道，首先会有一种完整感。
This is Todd Lockwood again, the founder of the library.
这是托德·洛克伍德，图书馆的创始人。
And we heard this from numerous writers that sent us works. After their book had been in the collection for a while, we'd hear back from them, hear back from writers who would say, wow, this really is a weight off. I just feel like the project is done finally. Even though it technically was finished, it's the fact that it's sitting on a shelf in a public place, where someone that that person doesn't know will cross paths with that book, and take it off the shelf, and perhaps read it. That sort of completes the circle, and I can get on to the next thing.
我们从无数寄给我们作品的作家那里听到过。在他们的书在收藏中放了一段时间后，我们会收到回音，听到那些作家说，哇，这真的是放下了重担。我觉得这个项目终于完成了。尽管从技术上讲它已经完成了，但事实是它放在公共场所的书架上，那个作者不认识的人会与那本书擦肩而过，把它从书架上拿下来，也许读一读。那样的循环完成了，我就可以进入下一件事了。
It's funny to think about, but in some ways, The Brautigan Library is more like the library in the novel now than it ever has been. The books are housed in a building that looks more like the Presidio branch. They aren't often read by anyone. And it has one librarian, who actually is available at all hours of the day and night to accept new books, but only digitized ones, PDFs submitted online.
想起来很有趣，但在某些方面，布劳提根图书馆现在比以往任何时候都更像小说里的图书馆。书存放在一栋看起来更像普雷西迪奥分馆的建筑里。它们并不常被任何人阅读。它有一位图书管理员，实际上可以在白天和晚上的任何时间接受新书，但只能是数字化的，在线提交的PDF。
But the more I think about it, it's not about how perfectly or imperfectly Todd or John turned a fictional place into a real one. That's not the point. It's that Richard Brautigan in his novel predicted with perfect accuracy what would happen if you did create a library like this. That being there would give you a feeling like you're walking down the street and noticing that everyone has a book they've made tucked under one arm, a jumbled woolly individual transcription of how the world feels to that person.
但我越想越觉得，这不在于托德或约翰把一个虚构的地方变成真实的地方有多完美或不完美。那不是重点。重点是理查德·布劳提根在他的小说里准确预言了如果你确实创造了一个这样的图书馆会发生什么。身处其中会让你感觉像是在街上走，注意到每个人胳膊下都夹着一本他们自己制作的书，一份混乱的、羊毛般的、个人化的转录，关于世界对那个人而言是什么感觉。
It's the feeling of being able to read everyone's mind for a moment and being startled by their unedited thoughts because they're nothing like yours, but they're just as weird. It's like the librarian says in chapter two of the novel, "There just simply had to be a library like this."
那种感觉就像瞬间能读懂每个人的心思，并被他们未经编辑的想法吓了一跳，因为它们和你的一点也不像，但却同样怪异。就像小说第二章里图书管理员所说的，“仅仅是因为必须有这样一个图书馆。”
Sean Cole, who's one of the producers of our program. Coming up, a woman who went to the library every day for a while as a child suddenly realizes one day as an adult that the way she was remembering it was not right at all. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
肖恩·科尔，我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，一个小时候有一段时间每天都去图书馆的女人，成年后突然意识到她记忆中它的样子完全不对。一分钟后回来。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "The Room of Requirement," we have stories of how libraries function like a real-life version of that room in Harry Potter, the Room of Requirement. Where when you need something, the room just makes it appear for you, just like librarians try to do. Seriously, all over the world. Whatever your request. We have arrived at the third act of our program. Act Three, Growing Shelf Awareness.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，“有求必应屋”，我们有关于图书馆如何像哈利·波特里那个有求必应屋的现实版本一样的故事。当你需要什么时，房间就会为你显现，就像图书管理员尝试做的那样。认真地，在世界各地。无论你有什么请求。我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，增加书架意识。
This act is about somebody returning to the library that she went to as a kid, wanting something very specific and very personal out of that experience. One of our producers, Stephanie Foo, went with her.
这一幕是关于某人回到她小时候去过的图书馆，想从那次经历中得到一些非常具体和个人化的东西。我们的制作人之一，斯蒂芬妮·傅，陪她一起去了。
Lydia Sigwarth walks into her childhood library in Dubuque. It's this huge stone building with Roman columns, built over 100 years ago. And as soon as we pass the front door, Lydia stops dead in her tracks, looks up at the large, echoey rotunda above us, and gets quiet.
莉迪亚·西格沃斯走进她在迪比克的童年图书馆。这是一栋巨大的石质建筑，带有罗马柱，建于100多年前。我们一经过前门，莉迪亚就停下了脚步，抬头看着我们上方巨大、有回声的圆形大厅，安静了下来。
Do you remember how you felt walking into the library when you were a kid?
你还记得小时候走进图书馆的感觉吗？
It was my favorite part of each day, and I always had a plan. I always came with a plan of what I wanted to do.
这是我每天最喜欢的部分，我总是有个计划。我总是带着我想做什么的计划来的。
This was her favorite place growing up. She only lives half an hour away now, but she hasn't been a patron here in nearly two decades. Back when she was six, Lydia, her mom, and her six siblings used to spend a lot of time here. Like a lot of time. They spent all day, almost everyday here for about half a year, while they were homeless.
这是她成长过程中最喜欢的地方。她现在只住半小时车程远，但她近二十年没来这里做读者了。当她六岁时，莉迪亚、她的妈妈和她的六个兄弟姐妹经常在这里花很多时间。就像花很多时间。他们大约有半年时间，几乎每天都在这里待上一整天，那时他们无家可归。
We walk past a World War I exhibit into an airy space filled with nonfiction books and people working on computers.
我们经过一个一战展览，进入了一个充满非虚构类书籍和人们在电脑上工作通风良好的空间。
This was where the children's department used to be, I'm pretty sure.
我确定以前儿童部就在这里。
We go around the crafting zone into a quiet area by a big floor-to-ceiling window that looks out on the street.
我们绕过工艺区，进入靠近对着街道的大落地窗的一个安静区域。
This was a very warm spot because of the window. I remember it being very cozy and warm.
因为窗户的原因，这里是一个非常温暖的地方。我记得它非常舒适和温暖。
There's some cushion chairs here. Those are new. Back then, they'd sit on the floor.
这里有一些垫子椅子。那些是新的。那时候，他们会坐在地板上。
My little brother would take his nap here. This was a quieter spot, where we're sitting right now. And I remember my eldest sister holding my little brother who's two at the time. And he was sleeping, and she would quietly read a book out loud to me.
我的小弟弟会在这里打盹。这是一个更安静的地方，就在我们现在坐的地方。我记得我最大的姐姐抱着当时才两岁的小弟弟。他正在睡觉，她会轻声给我读一本书。
This used to be next to a big shelf, where they kept all The Boxcar Children books. They were free to run around unassisted, without parents hovering over them, to do whatever they wanted. If you think about it, libraries are kind of one of the only public spaces where kids have freedom like that. And so Lydia ran through the stacks, and crawled around on the play rug, or just stared out of this big window, her favorite, near where her baby brother used to sleep.
以前这里靠近一个大书架，他们存放所有《箱车小孩》的书。他们可以自由地四处奔跑，不需要父母徘徊在身边，做任何他们想做的事。如果你想想，图书馆是孩子们拥有这种自由的唯一公共空间之一。所以莉迪亚穿过书架，在地毯上爬来爬去，或者只是盯着这扇大窗户，这是她最喜欢的，就在她弟弟睡觉的地方附近。
I forgot about this. So the entrance is below us right now. And I would watch people come in and out because we'd be here for hours at a time. And I would watch people come in and then wait for them to come back out and see how many books they had.
我忘了这个。入口就在我们下面。我会看着人们进进出出，因为我们一次会在这里待上几个小时。我会看着人们进来，然后等他们出来，看看他们有多少本书。
Lydia came from a stable family, but when they moved from Denver to Dubuque, they had a tough time finding a place they could afford. So they crashed with friends and family, moving every month or two. Lydia remembers all nine of them, crammed together in someone's basement. She and her five sisters all slept together on a big L-shaped couch, with blow-up mattresses in the middle. And every morning, Lydia's mom would pack up all the kids and take them to the library.
莉迪亚来自一个稳定的家庭，但当他们从丹佛搬到迪比克时，他们很难找到负担得起的地方。所以他们和朋友及家人挤在一起，每个月或两个月搬一次。莉迪亚记得他们九个人挤在某人的地下室里。她和五个姐妹挤在大大的L型沙发上，中间放着充气床垫。每天早上，莉迪亚的妈妈会收拾好所有孩子带到图书馆。
I think that's why they took us here, is to give the family we were staying with privacy, but also to give us our own measures of privacy.
我想这就是他们带我们来这里的原因，是为了给我们要住的人家隐私，但也为了给我们自己的隐私空间。
Because it's so big. You could--
因为这里太大了。你可以——
We could spread out and have our own spots. So I had spots here, and you can't have a spot in a furnished basement shared with eight other people.
我们可以分散开来，有我们自己的位置。所以我在这里有位置，而在和八个人共用的装修过的地下室里，你不可能有位置。
Her parents did such a good job pretending that they were just on a fun adventure, that Lydia didn't register any of this as painful or difficult. She didn't even really understand that their family was going through anything, until she was having a conversation at work about a year ago, talking about homeless people coming to the library.
她的父母做得太好了，假装他们只是在进行一次有趣的冒险，莉迪亚并没有把这一切注册为痛苦或困难。她甚至没真正明白他们的家庭正在经历什么，直到大约一年前她在工作中进行了一次对话，谈到无家可归的人来图书馆。
It came rushing back to her. Wait a minute, that was me. She honestly had never thought about it for almost two decades.
记忆如潮水般涌回她。等等，那是我。她真的近二十年没想过这件事。
And I'm sitting in this meeting, like almost crying, like I teared up. I was like, how did I never realize this before? And how did we never talk about this? And then I was like, it's because it wasn't traumatic. We were fine. We were happy. We were fed, and clothed, and taken care of. So there was nothing wrong. Because I remembered that time so fondly, that I was like, oh, that was the year we lived in the library. It was the best time ever.
我坐在那个会议里，快哭出来一样，眼里含着泪。我说，我怎么从来没意识到这一点？我们怎么从来没谈过这个？然后我说，那是因为那并不痛苦。我们很好。我们快乐，有吃有穿，被照顾得很好。所以没什么不对的。因为我非常喜欢那段时间，以至于我说，哦，那是我们住在图书馆的一年。那是有史以来最好的时光。
I just remember the feeling that it gave me, of belonging. I get really emotional thinking about it because I credit Mrs. S for most of it.
我只记得它给我的那种归属感。想到它我会非常激动，因为我把大部分功劳归于S夫人。
Mrs. S was the children's librarian. Lydia's favorite spot in the library was by her desk.
S夫人是儿童图书管理员。莉迪亚在图书馆最喜欢的地方是在她的桌子旁。
It was a round desk, like a half moon round desk. So I would make a beeline over here and make my demands known. [LAUGHS]
那是一张圆桌，像半月形的圆桌。所以我总是直奔这里，说出我的要求。（笑）
Every morning, all seven kids would run in and spread out over her library. But every day, Mrs. S would greet them warmly. She'd stroll the stacks with Lydia, helping her find something to read. They had conversations about books and about life. Lydia remembers this one day in particular, when Mrs. S came up to her with a recommendation.
每天早上，所有七个孩子都会跑进来，分散在她的图书馆里。但每天，S夫人都会热情地迎接他们。她会和莉迪亚一起在书架中漫步，帮她找书看。他们会聊书和生活。莉迪亚特别记得有一天，S夫人带着推荐走近她。
I remember her putting aside the book, The Twelve Dancing Princesses, for me. I remember her bringing it to me and saying that this came back, and I thought of you right away when I saw it because you have sisters. So I got this for you.
我记得她为我留下了《十二个跳舞的公主》这本书。我记得她把它带给我说，这本书还回来了，我看到它时立刻想到了你，因为你有姐妹。所以我为你拿了这本书。
It was the first book that felt perfect for her. The youngest princess in the book was the heroine, and she was also the youngest sister in her family. She was sure Mrs. S was telling her that she was special.
这是第一本感觉对她而言完美的书。书里的最小公主是女英雄，她也是家里最小的姐妹。她确信S夫人是在告诉她她是特别的。
Lydia wanted to find Mrs. S for a few years because she had such great memories of her, but who exactly was she? Lydia had no idea what the S stood for, like what her real last name was. She visited the library once to ask, and they said they weren't sure. It had been decades. But there was a Mrs. Stephenson who had worked here a long time. Only problem was she couldn't talk to her that day because she was on vacation. So Lydia just went home.
莉迪亚想找S夫人找了几年，因为她对她有很美好的回忆，但她究竟是谁？莉迪亚根本不知道S代表什么，她的真名是什么。她去图书馆问过一次，他们说不确定。那已经过去几十年了。但有一位斯蒂芬森夫人在这里工作了很久。唯一的问题是她那天不能和她说话，因为她在休假。所以莉迪亚就回家了。
Then about a year ago, when all of the memories of her being homeless came flooding back, she wrote a long email to say thank you and sent it to Mrs. Stephenson. But she never got a response. Lydia thought, it's probably not the right Mrs. S, or maybe she doesn't remember me.
然后大约一年前，当她无家可归的所有记忆涌回时，她写了一封长邮件表示感谢并寄给了斯蒂芬森夫人。但她从未收到回复。莉迪亚想，可能那不是那位S夫人，或者她不记得我了。
We get to go to the staff only. Very exciting.
我们可以去仅限员工进入的地方。太让人兴奋了。
So I'll just tell you. I called ahead, and yep, Mrs. Stephenson was Mrs. S. And yes, she totally remembered Lydia. So we went to see her in the staff only area. It was the first time Lydia had seen her since she was a little kid. Mrs. S was sitting in a big, warm office, decorated with paintings of cows and pink monsters. And when she saw Lydia, she rushed out with her arms wide open and grabbed her into a huge hug.
我就直接告诉你吧。我提前打了电话，没错，斯蒂芬森夫人就是S夫人。而且没错，她完全记得莉迪亚。所以我们去仅限员工的区域去看她。这是莉迪亚自小时候以来第一次见她。S夫人坐在一个大而温暖的办公室里，装饰着牛和粉色怪物的画。当她看到莉迪亚时，她张开双臂冲了出来，给了她一个大大的拥抱。
[LAUGHS] Hi, sweetheart.
（笑）嗨，甜心。
Hi.
嗨。
Aww, you look the same.
噢，你看上去一样。
Do I?
是吗？
Yes, just taller.
是的，只是更高了。
Do you remember me?
你还记得我吗？
I remember your family.
我记得你的家人。
Aww because we were here all the time.
噢，因为我们一直在这里。
Mm-hmm. Yeah, that's what I remember. Golly!
嗯哼。是啊，我记得的就是那样。天哪！
Try to think of the last person you've met who used the word "golly" with all sincerity. I can see why Mrs. S made her feel cared for.
试着想一下你最近见过哪个人真诚地使用“天哪”这个词。我能看出为什么S夫人让她觉得被照顾。
I brought you a present that is very badly wrapped. I don't know what happened to my ribbon.
我给你带了一件包装得很糟糕的礼物。我不知道我的丝带去哪了。
Then I think it's beautiful now.
然后我觉得它现在很漂亮。
Thank you.
谢谢。
[WRAPPING CRINKLING]
（包装纸起皱声）
It is, of course, a copy of The Twelve Dancing Princesses.
当然是《十二个跳舞的公主》的副本。
Oh, my God! Did I introduce this book to you?
哦，天哪！是我向你介绍这本书的吗？
You did.
是的。
It's my very favorite book of all time.
这是我一生中最喜欢的一本书。
That's so funny because I thought it was special for me.
太搞笑了，因为我以为它对我而言是特别的。
Well, of course it was!
嗯，它当然是！
Then Lydia asks Mrs. S, did she read her letter? Turns out Mrs. S never got it. We figure it probably got caught by her spam filter. And so Lydia starts to explain everything about that moment recently where she realized she'd been homeless.
然后莉迪亚问S夫人，她读过她的信了吗？原来S夫人从没收到。我们估计它可能被她的垃圾邮件过滤器拦截了。于是莉迪亚开始解释最近她意识到自己曾经无家可归的那一刻的所有事情。
This was my home for that year, and I felt like I belonged. I belonged, and I was safe here. And I believe that was partially due to your influence, for me.
那是我的家，那一年我感到我属于那里。我属于那里，在这里我是安全的。我相信那部分是因为你的影响。
Oh, oh. Aww! I can't-- I give your parents all that credit. I knew, but I-- we just-- no! It's your mom and dad.
噢，噢。噢！我不能——我把所有的功劳都归于你的父母。我知道，但我——我们只是——不！是你妈妈和爸爸。
And I really do give them so much credit, but my memories from that time are all of you treating me so well. And I felt so important here. I felt like you thought that I was just the greatest, and it just means so much.
我确实把很多功劳都归于他们，但我对那段时间的记忆全是你们对我非常好。我在这里感到自己很重要。我觉得你认为我就是最好的，那真的意义非凡。
Aww, I just think that's wonderful.
噢，我觉得那太美妙了。
That's the sound of a hug.
那是拥抱的声音。
It's everyday life for the library.
这是图书馆的日常生活。
It is! It is.
它是！它是。
It's what we do.
这就是我们要做的。
Do you remember knowing about the family situation when they were in?
你还记得当他们来的时候，知道他们的情况吗？
I didn't know the exacts of the family situation. We just knew. We just knew. They were here every day. It was obvious.
我不知道情况的具体细节。我们只是知道。我们只是知道。他们每天都在这里。这很明显。
Lydia starts nodding effusively to what Mrs. S is saying. She knows exactly what she's talking about because Lydia works with those kids everyday herself. She's a librarian, a children's librarian.
莉迪亚开始赞许地点头回应S夫人所说的话。她完全知道她在说什么，因为莉迪亚自己每天都在和那些孩子一起工作。她是一位图书管理员，一位儿童图书管理员。
And you became a librarian?
你成为了图书管理员？
I did because of you.
我是因为你才成为的。
I think it's awesome. You don't realize how much influence you have on anybody, just by doing your job.
我觉得这太棒了。你没意识到仅仅通过你的工作，你对任何人有多大的影响。
You keep saying you were just doing your job, and I feel like I need to say, though, that you did not have to be that kind. You could have done your job without being that eternally kind. And that's something that I think about a lot because there are situations with children that I know are coming from difficult places or children who are there all day, and they just need a lot from me.
你一直说你只是在做你的工作，但我感觉我需要说，你不需要那么善良。你可以不做那份恒久的善良来完成你的工作。这是我经常想的事情，因为我知道有些孩子的情况来自困难的地方，或者那些整天待在那里的孩子，他们只是从我这里需要很多。
And there are days when I don't want to be the most kind person on the planet because I'm tired or the child is being challenging. There are always those days. But you were that kind.
有些日子我不想成为星球上最善良的人，因为我累了，或者孩子表现得很困难。总是会有那些日子。但你当时就是那么善良。
Yes, the girl who lived at the library grew up to become a librarian, helping other kids like her.
是的，住在图书馆的女孩长大后成为了图书管理员，帮助其他像她一样的孩子。
I'll have families that, I would say, most of the kids that are there all the time, it's because they don't want to be home or don't have a stable home. And I hope I'm doing the same thing for my kids. It's so important to me.
会有一些家庭，我会说，大多数整天待在那里的孩子，是因为他们不想待在家里，或者没有一个稳定的家。我希望我能为我的孩子做同样的事。这对我来说太重要了。
You are. I don't think you have to hope. I know you are, just by watching and seeing your reactions today. I know you are. You are.
你正在做。我觉得你不需要希望。我知道你是，通过观看和看到你今天的反应。我知道你是。你是。
Thank you. [SNIFFLES]
谢谢。（抽泣）
You're welcome. Absolutely. Just continue to do what you're doing. It's obvious.
不客气。绝对是这样。继续做你正在做的事。这很明显。
I'm just going to cry now for a little while. It's fine.
我只是要哭一会了。没关系。
The two women swap numbers in their phones. They make a date to get fried pickles in Platteville and to talk shop about disenfranchised youth and best practices at story time.
这两个女人在电话里交换了号码。她们定好去普拉特维尔吃炸泡菜，谈谈关于边缘化青少年和讲故事时间最佳实践的生意。
I visited the Platteville library, where Lydia has been a children's librarian for eight years. And I have to say she's really great at her job. She pinballs from one side of the room to another, helping one kid fix her computer, making sure others are safe as they walk out.
我访问了普拉特维尔图书馆，莉迪亚在那里担任了八年的儿童图书管理员。我不得不说她在工作上真的很棒。她在房间的一侧到另一侧来回奔波，帮助一个孩子修理她的电脑，确保其他人走出去时是安全的。
Well, it's gone black. That's a great sign. There we go!
好吧，它变黑了。那是个好迹象。就是这样！
Yes!
是的！
Yes. OK, we fixed it.
是的。好的，我们修好了。
Now let me listen to my song.
现在让我听我的歌。
How are you doing, bud? Good? Good. All right.
你还好吗，伙计？好的？好的。好吧。
It's probably a better idea to put coats on.
穿上外套可能是一个更好的主意。
She brought in her parents' scale and used some old x-rays to make a fake hospital and has a fish named Fishstick that the kids help take care of.
她带进了父母的秤，用一些旧X光片做了一个模拟医院，还有一条叫Fishstick的鱼，孩子们帮着照顾。
[RUNNING FAUCET]
（水龙头流水声）
Oops.
噢。
Are we gonna fill it up--
我们要把它填满——
We are going to fill it up.
我们要把它填满。
--with toilet water?
——用厕所水？
Not with toilet water.
不是用厕所水。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
The windows have little reading nooks in them and a giant bear to cuddle with named Sir Fluffy Puffy McBearson. On April Fool's Day, she set up a self checkout line. It was just a mirror at the counter. Get it? She also holds her monthly book club, where she and a bunch of kids talk about their readings, but also build things out of stacked books, and create funny videos, and play games.
窗户有小小的阅读角，还有一个叫Sir Fluffy Puffy McBearson的巨大熊可以拥抱。在愚人节，她设立了一条自助结账线。那只是柜台上的镜子。懂了吗？她还举行每月的读书俱乐部，她和一群孩子谈论他们的阅读，也用堆叠的书籍建造东西，制作有趣的视频，玩游戏。
I talked to a couple of kids who said they used to hate reading, but now they love it, all because of Miss Lydia's book club.
我和几个孩子谈过，他们说以前讨厌阅读，但现在他们热爱它，全是因为莉迪亚小姐的读书俱乐部。
I want to know where the shadow puppet books are.
我想知道影子木偶书在哪里。
Shadow puppets. You want to learn how to make shadow puppets?
影子木偶。你想学怎么制作影子木偶？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
OK, let's do that.
好的，我们开始吧。
Lydia has one girl at her library who is there all the time, every day. We'll call her Anna. Anna reminds Lydia of herself growing up, but she's had it harder.
莉迪亚在她的图书馆里有一个女孩，她总是在那里，每一天。我们叫她安娜。安娜让莉迪亚想起成长过程中的自己，但她过得更艰难。
Her living arrangements aren't stable. She's often hungry. Lydia worries about her when she disappears for a week. One day about a year ago when Anna was 9, she had the same impulse with Lydia that Lydia had with Mrs. S. Anna wrote her a letter.
她的居住安排不稳定。她经常挨饿。莉迪亚在安娜消失一周时会为她担心。大约一年前，当安娜9岁时，她对莉迪亚有了和莉迪亚对S夫人同样的冲动。安娜给她写了一封信。
It says, "Lydia is really nice. She's a really nice person. She's an intelligent, rememberative, and fast young woman. Sometimes when I'm at home, I just want to go to the library, just to see Lydia."
上面写着，“莉迪亚真的很善良。她是一个非常好的人。她是一个聪明、有纪念意义、迅速的年轻女子。有时当我在家时，我只是想去图书馆，仅仅是为了见到莉迪亚。”
Stephanie Foo.
斯蒂芬妮·傅。
Our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo. The people who put our show together includes Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Jared Floyd, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, Jay Kang, David Kestenbaum, Anna Martin, Stone Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·傅制作。制作我们节目的团队包括佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、贾里德·弗洛伊德、米歇尔·哈里斯、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、杰伊·康、大卫·克斯滕鲍姆、安娜·马丁、斯通·纳尔逊、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德。我们的执行主编是苏珊·伯顿。
The reporters who went to libraries for us at the top of the show. Jude Joffe-Block was in Phoenix. Liza Veale was in San Francisco. Rachael London was in Florida. And our producer, Anna Martin, was at the Blackfeet Indian Reservation in Montana. Thanks today to Eric Klinenberg, who spoke about libraries as palaces for the people. It was helpful to us as we thought about this week's show, as was Susan Orlean's book, The Library Book.
在节目开头为我们去图书馆的记者们。朱德·乔夫-布洛克在菲尼克斯。丽莎·维尔在旧金山。瑞秋·伦敦在佛罗里达。我们的制作人安娜·马丁在蒙大拿州的黑脚印第安保留地。感谢埃里克·克林伯格，他谈到了图书馆作为人民宫殿。这对我们思考本周的节目很有帮助，正如苏珊·奥尔良的书《图书馆书》一样。
Thanks also today to Ianthe Brautigan, William Steele, Elizabeth Jensen, William Hartston, Ashleyanne Krigbaum, Brian Belfiglio, Annie Proulx Marcia Popper, Brad Richardson and everybody at the Clark County Historical Museum, Michael Fast Buffalo Horse, Joe Rutherford, Bridgit Bowden, and Zach Goelman. Also thanks to the staffs of the Phoenix Public Library, the Queens Public Library, the Sumter County Public Library, the San Francisco Public Library, and the Medicine Spring Library.
也感谢今天的一安西·布劳提根、威廉·斯蒂尔、伊丽莎白·詹森、威廉·哈特斯顿、阿什莉安妮·克里格鲍姆、布莱恩·贝尔菲利奥、安妮·普鲁、马西娅·波普尔、布拉德·理查森以及克拉克县历史博物馆的每一个人、迈克尔·快水牛马、乔·卢瑟福、布里吉特·鲍登和扎克·戈尔曼。也感谢菲尼克斯公共图书馆、皇后区公共图书馆、萨姆特县公共图书馆、旧金山公共图书馆和医药泉图书馆的工作人员。
Our web site, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. We had the biggest fight the other day, him and me. I told him, look, it's like you think you're God or something. He didn't deny it.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600集的档案。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心传送给公共广播电台。感谢一如既往的我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。我们前几天吵了一架，他和我都。我告诉他，看，这就像你以为你是上帝一样。他没否认。
Yes, we look an awful lot alike. Tall, mustache, glasses.
是的，我们看起来非常像。高个子、胡子、眼镜。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多美国生活的故事。